The joe rogan experience.
I was influenced by hotel a massively.
Yeah,
like as a new faculty drinking too.
Did that,
oh no,
I was thing.
No I was fine.
I told you I came in,
explained that because this is a crazy story.
You didn't say this on the podcast.
I have when I was in 1997,
Rollingstone magazine wrote a six and a half page article about me calling me
the number one party in the mall in the country.
It's actually gets a little weirder.
But are you doing standup back then?
No,
just partying.
Just had a notorious reputation of Florida state for being like funny,
but being a wild party animal.
Like what kind of Shit were you doing?
Just Fun Shit.
Like uh,
like fun.
I think Wa loudest guy in the room.
Shit.
You know like I remember I used to climb up on this telephone pole outside the
bars on Tennessee street.
There'll be 500 people out there and I just stand up.
I go,
everyone shut the fuck up and listen.
If you want to smoke weed,
go to my house and the cops are all sitting there.
I have tons of weed,
enough for everybody and we're all gonna have a blast and get eye.
If you know where I live.
You're invited.
If you don't ask someone,
just no one tell the fucking cops and you'd have literally 500 people just
giggling at the idea that someone was offering them weed in front of the cops
face.
And what are the cops say when you did this?
Uh,
they would laugh too.
Like one time for an election,
uh,
gotten naked for this election and just shit on a pizza box and won the election
election for what?
For my fraternity or just got up naked and shit on a pizza box and then every
you want.
And then I won.
Did you wipe?
Not just shit.
I just shit,
I learned one very important lesson when you go number two,
you also go one,
cause I pissed all over the feet on everyone that was sitting.
I can't stop it when you go one.
And so I won the election.
So like all these stories came out and then rolling stones like let's do a
fucking,
let's do an article on him.
Oh my God.
It gets crazier.
Ready?
Sorry for the you already for the part that you go that you go bullshit.
I will never say bull shit.
I've heard enough of your stories.
So uh,
so Oliver Stone optioned the rights to my life and then from the article.
So then I try to stand up and I moved to New York to start doing stamps.
I did it once and to in a tile house,
you know,
we went amazing.
I can offer my own morning show in Tallahassee.
Really?
Yeah.
Oliver Stone option.
The rights in my life.
Like I start doing stand up five minutes later will Smith sees me to stand up
and I get a deal development deal with him.
Like right out the gate it's like bill burst style,
like been doing standup for no time at all.
Development deal based on the article and that the fact that I could competently
do stand up somewhat and then the development deal falls apart with Oliver
Stone.
All the guys that have submitted their scripts for Oliver Stone's movie about my
life,
then get their intellectual property back.
One of the guy takes his movie changes,
my name sells at National Lampoon and it becomes a movie Van Wilder.
So theoretically,
and I say this theoretically loosely,
I'll never be able to sue.
I'm never would sue,
I never would sue.
But I went into national lampoon and did,
do you remember Kevin Couch?
He used to have a showing nationally,
XM radio.
And I told him,
I said,
bring some exact sin.
I've always wanted to find out if this is true.
So then he brought some execs in and
I start telling the story just like I am you one of the guys fucking locks up.
Like,
hold on,
stop right now.
What do you want?
What's going on here?
Is this like an ambush?
And I was like,
no,
I just want to be able to tell it on radio and no,
I'm not lying.
That's all I care about.
All I care about is the story being like true.
And he was like,
what do you want?
Like your own radio show.
I'm like,
Ugh,
fine.
And then he's like,
we'll do a show parting with the original Dan while are you happy?
And I was like yeah.
And so then he was like pretty much I was like so I can say true but yeah we're
worried you were going to sue them.
We were telling stories this week and about like,
like one time at okay one time,
one morning I thought I was,
my parents were at a town,
my little sister was 10,
I was probably 21 I was drinking a lot at the time cause it was you know,
party animal shit.
And then I was pissing a lot of places that like in the round houses like I
pissed on my ex girlfriend's dining room table and was walked in by her dad.
Do you want to talk about a fucking nightmare?
Waiting,
waiting,
waiting.
Were you pissed on the dining room?
MEDOC her dad walked in and caught her dad,
Larry Medoc in Orlando.
Larry,
if you're listening,
I,
I w I'm guilty.
I so here's,
okay cause I never really accepted blame for it.
I always said it never fucking happened cause it cause I didn't want it to cause
I didn't want,
okay,
why did you do it was thanksgiving.
It was right after the rolling stone magazine came out and so,
and I go back to party on what do you mean the rolling Stone magazine with a
number,
the rolling stone in 1997 call me the number one party animal in the country
just for someone who doesn't know and then that was a big deal.
I became famous and I became famous in like Tampa,
Florida,
Tampa,
Tallahassee,
Gainesville,
Orlando,
anywhere that I had people with four went to Florida state lived,
I was paying you.
They knew who I was.
They were like,
cause the fucker party guy.
So if I went out shots really we'd any do people put drugs in my hand like it
was fucking insane.
I get Roofie I got roof a couple of times.
So you became like a celebrity partier.
I became the guy that I'd walk after the,
before the article,
I was just the loud,
fun,
shirtless guy on top of the bar,
getting everyone in a frenzy.
And then when the article came out it was like the fucking lineman would come to
the bar.
I drank at Yonnie's and they'd pull me aside and they're like,
you're drinking with us tonight.
We want to drink with a party animal.
And then I just be up with these lines and like four lineman and we'd be just
doing shots and shots and shots and these guys are 350 pounds,
two to 18 at the time,
probably like going through to 18 and probably more like two 25 but,
but and so I became like,
like I say famous,
I say like reality show famous like the way Snookie her first season was,
you know,
so that's how you were in your town and you're in Tallahassee.
If I went like right after that article came out in Tallahassee,
definitely in Orlando,
I knew 40% of the bar knew who I was in Tampa.
Everyone knew who I was back when people actually read magazines that it's
bigger reality shows before the Internet,
before the Internet is a big one for,
it's like you were in this,
so like you were was on Oprah called and wanted me to be on her show,
but she wanted my parents to be on to,
and mom was like,
I'm not gonna do that at my fucking parents.
So I did everything I did like fucking they sent you ready for this?
This is how bizarre this eight period period got,
they sent ESPN send a tour bus with two actors in it to come shoot a commercial
of partying with me of what it's like to party with a number one party animal
for the x games.
Right.
They wanted to like the,
and one of the actors was Johnny Knoxville,
fucking bizarre shit.
So Johnny Knoxville,
we meet and he says,
you do drugs.
And I was like,
I was like,
in my head,
I'm like,
yeah,
I'm an adult.
Let's do it.
So going to this tour bus,
I never done pills like pills.
And so he liked pores like Clemson on shit.
Nope,
nope.
Yeah,
little stronger.
Probably like Pete Tylenol PM probably still.
He's just poured some tea,
some Tylenol or whatever it was.
He pours it with my hand.
And so I like thumb one,
like finger one,
hold it down and he gives me too and I pop one and then he starts passing a bow.
So you are being calculated about it.
I was like,
I don't know what the fuck I'm taking.
I have no idea.
And I haven't started drinking.
I haven't done it.
Like I'm just like,
what the fuck?
And then not like someone might not die of a fucking overdose around on that
guy.
Yes,
but he,
this was before jackass.
This is,
they were just great.
This is like five,
10 years before jackass.
Those are wild dunes.
And Johnny Knoxville is passing bills around and he's lightened a Bong Bong hits
and he's,
you gotta be careful with that guy videos he's putting in videos of,
of,
of uh,
of Bam.
Margera trying to bring a bottle over his head and he's like,
watch this.
And I were laughing our tits off.
This is well before anyone knows what the fuck this is.
And then I look at the other guy,
I forgot the other guy's name,
but I go,
what was that?
And he was like,
dilauded you never had dilauded go it's dilaudid.
it's like pharmaceutical heroin.
It's awesome.
You're gonna love it.
And I was like,
thank God I only took one.
Jesus Christ.
That's like what?
Like they used to give chicks in the wild west movies.
Yeah.
When they had an issue.
I have,
she needs some dilaudid.
Dilaudid.
Yeah.
So we ended up partying all night.
We take this tour bus out,
fill it up,
dresses,
women,
throw herself down the stairs.
This is women fucking the corner of the craziest nights that drinking beer
bottles over our heads.
It was the craziest fucking night of my life.
Cut.
Uh Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
So,
um,
there were no,
they were,
they were a fake breakaway beer bottles.
But we were like,
but we had seen Bam do it and we thought it was funny.
So we were doing it with these fake breakaway bottles but were outfitted with a
real bottle.
Bam.
I think it was Bam and his posse.
But it was the CKY posse.
They were trying to break a beer bottle over their head.
The rolling stone stuff was crazy when that came out.
It was like being famous.
Cut Back to how I pissed on my girlfriend's table.
Yes.
So thank you.
So that was like unwinding.
That was like untangling a necklace.
So,
so we go out in Orlando,
this is right after Thanksgiving when everyone's home.
So everyone I know from Orlando's at every bar,
all in like church street I think is the name of the street.
So we go out and it's fucking chaos.
I'm with my girlfriend,
her sister and her sister's boyfriend who was the coolest fucking guy and he'll
always have weed.
So we go out and buying me shots.
We're getting fucking hammered.
Her parents had just bought a house,
just bought this brand new house just like I,
and it was their dream house.
We had Thanksgiving together.
We held hands,
talked about how at the table,
how this is everything we've worked for guys as a team.
We saved,
we scrimped week anyway,
we go back to her house and I'm like,
I'm not fucking done.
Like I want to keep drinking and this Guy Dan,
he's like,
oh yeah,
me too.
So we get like a 12 pack of beer and we'd go out to the dock and d and that's
all I remember Danny.
Then the next morning we counts everything to me because my,
she walks in the first thing in the morning,
did you piss on my dining room table?
And I'm like,
no,
why would I fucking do that?
I'm a grown man.
I don't piss on tables.
She was like,
my dad said he caught you pissing on our table.
I'm like,
your dad is crazy.
He doesn't like me cause I'm in the party animal and he's trying to get me out
of your life.
That's what's fucking going on.
And you can gather.
Fuck I can remember going to blame me.
I'm the party animal.
No,
I'm straight.
I'm sure.
I'm sure
the fuck you're talking to right now.
He wants me out of your life.
Number one party animal,
the country,
but something to that.
Yeah,
I'm sure I actually used the words so
you probably had it.
She should have it explaining it.
Aw.
Did you ever think about getting,
I'm the party animal tattooed anywhere in your body.
I was thinking about getting a squirrel with a beer can and a cigarette that
said the party squirrel on at one time.
Who's going to fucking question that too so we can tell me what your 10 to
about.
If I pulled you over,
if I was a cop and I pulled you over and you had a party squirrel Tatooine I
immediately take you to jail.
I'm like,
I know this guy did something fucked up in the last couple of months.
You've just got to get it out of them.
We just going to sit down and go,
you know what you did?
Just tell me we know what you did.
Just tell me.
We'll all get out of here early.
We'll get you a nice quick sentence.
Just tell me what happened.
So I don't even know what you're talking about.
Okay,
so,
so she get back in your fucking car.
She goes out to the breakfast table where family is.
Oh my God,
how much piss are we talking about here?
In my head,
it didn't happen.
And your head,
You didn't highly blacked out.
Fucking,
I swear to you,
all my children right now,
I laid in that bed,
rolled over,
and I went,
how far Wayman then how do you,
how do you know your home?
He didn't fucking sell you down the river.
Maybe he pissed on a table and then say that you did it.
That's why he woke you up in the morning.
He knew you blacked out and then you blame you for pissing on the table.
That's what's going through my head right now.
As I rolled back over and I go,
fuck them.
Maybe you can go bad if your,
but maybe,
maybe that would be called shitting,
but yeah,
maybe we call it a Brian train wreck.
You smoking a regular cigarette over there?
No,
it's got wheat in it.
All right.
So,
so Danny,
the boyfriend comes in and he's like,
comes in and his eyes are like so excited.
He goes,
I heard you piss on their table.
And I'm like,
no,
why is everyone fucking saying that?
And he's like,
cause her dad walked in on your pissing on the table and I said,
he's fucking lying.
He goes,
man,
he is pretty set in the,
he saw you pissing on their dining room table.
And I go,
Danny,
I don't remember fucking anything.
He goes,
he goes,
well we got these beers.
We went out to their doc.
Do you remember that?
And I go,
yes.
And he was like,
and I had a joint.
And I go,
okay,
I remember that.
And he's like,
and then you ate the joint.
And I was like,
I don't that.
And he goes,
yeah,
I said,
hold this and you ate it and laughed.
And then we killed all the beers out there and I go,
fuck,
we did.
And he was like,
yeah.
And then you start piecing back like little things.
I go,
did we get stuck in a phone booth last night?
And he's like,
no,
we got locked in their food cabinet like in their,
in their food closet,
like a pantry because in their pantries were eating and their kitchen and then
this and this.
I start,
remember I go,
yeah,
so like a girlfriend come out.
The girlfriend's coming and it was a sliding door,
so it was,
we were eating and the girlfriends came out,
the sisters and they go,
you're fucking making a ton of noise.
So me and Danny went into the pantry and shut the door,
but then we couldn't figure out how to open it because there wasn't a handle.
You guys were hammered and he's had a pantry and they shoved you in the pantry
to quiet you down.
We shoved ourselves into the pantry so that we could continue eating.
We were like,
we're going to bed.
They left.
We went to the Pantry,
shut the door,
and then I remember sitting in the pantry.
I do remember this distinctly is us being in the pantry thinking we were in a
phone booth,
laughing how hard all,
they had all this food in this phone booth and we're like,
he believe this boom news has fucking Doritos in it.
So then that's all I remember.
So then he says to me,
he goes them and he's really adamant.
So he leaves.
I lay back down and I'm like,
I can't believe I'm being framed for this shit.
All the sudden I start,
do you ever have one of those we use,
remember the dream you had last night?
And I distinctly remember seeing her dad in his underwear.
In my dream.
I'm like,
wait,
I did have a dream about her dad and his underwear.
That's odd.
And then I was like,
but he was in here yelling at me.
There's not a jury.
And yet she has with an old man.
No,
he,
what happened was,
and this,
and then I start going,
oh shit,
this totally did happen.
I woke up in the middle of the night,
walked out to their dining room table,
erect and tried to go to the bathroom.
You know how you kind of try to lean it down.
So I must have been making a ton of noise at their dining room table.
Pissed on their dining room table,
full blown pissed on their dining.
When you tell me this now,
now I'm remembering.
I'm like,
Oh shit,
I fucking do remember.
You remember being erect?
I remember,
I just remember trying to pee.
You know how when you have one of those nights where you're like in the
bathroom,
you're like,
I can't get to like lean forward.
So I'm leaning forward over their dining room table,
trying to Piss,
making a ton of noise,
knocking everything off of it.
He comes out in his tighty whities I remember that because she came back in and
I go to see your dad were tidy whities and she goes,
he does well,
I don't want to,
nevermind.
I then you can't dream.
I like,
no one wears off.
So anyway,
I dream about tighty whities twenties let's say 26 25 so here's the worst part.
He yells at me and he goes,
where the fuck?
What the fuck are you doing?
And I said,
I'm going to bed.
And he said,
where's your bed?
And I,
and I pointed to the dining room table.
I go right here.
And he goes,
what?
So I,
David Blaine the tablecloth,
pull it,
lay on the bed on the,
on top of their table at the table.
You pissed him in my own business and my own this in a superman,
cape full of Piss,
just lit curtain myself.
Go back to sleep and he gets me up and walked me into my bed and puts back in my
bed.
And I'm like,
what a nice guy.
We,
it gets so with our relationship was fucking doomed.
Like there was no,
I get up.
That is a nice guy.
He's a really nice Larry Maddock is a saint because if that happened on one of
my daughters and my house,
I would have beat the fucking kid's ass.
So I get up.
Would you really man?
No.
Do it like that again though.
I would beat the fucking kids ass.
Passionate your voice.
Have you ever considered acting?
Maybe Ip?
All the time when I'm really wasted.
Like if I black out drunk night,
I'll wake up and think like,
Oh,
I have to pee right now.
And I always like put on a shirt the next morning like,
oh,
why is it smelled like urine odd?
I did it again.
I'm done.
I do it all the time when I drink a lot.
So when you drank a lot,
you'll piss the bed.
I think I get confused and I wake up and I'm like,
I just pee on my champions suitcases alive.
Like
really drunk people.
Peanut suitcases.
Yeah.
That's actually fairly common.
Yeah,
it happens maybe twice a year.
The last time you were here,
there's a fucking story about the Russian mob.
We tease these bitches.
We let these people right now on Twitter,
they have been going crazy all day.
Do not let Bert Kreischer get out of there without the Russian mob story.
Right.
Tell us what the fuck happened.
All right.
This is in 1993 probably I think is what I went to Russia.
I was taking rushing classes at Florida state.
I thought they were Spanish classes because I thought there has been this
glasses because I,
it was a noon class and I signed up and then I was like,
fucking sweet Spanish at noon.
I can phone that in.
And then I get there and they start writing in a new language and new alphabet.
And I'm like,
all right,
this clearly isn't Spanish.
So then I said,
I'm going to leave.
And the teacher's like,
listen,
don't leave.
Um,
because if you leave,
we can't have a class and I can't get my master's degree.
So,
but if you stick around,
I'll talk to,
you have to have class.
I get done the end of the class.
She was like,
listen,
don't,
uh,
you know,
if you don't leave and I want and just show up at class,
I'll give you a c.
I was like,
done,
done.
So I took Russian,
I took Russian one,
two,
and three because these kids need it,
another guy in the class to take these classes.
So then finally I take rush.
I'd take it right from when we go to Russia,
we go to Russia.
But this is Rochelle.
Like when the mob ran Russia,
like are you,
are you guys aware of that?
No.
Okay.
In like the nine late nineties mid nineties the Marbury and everything that had
to do with Russia.
So when going over to Russia,
you had to,
you had to literally pay off the mob in order to go and study abroad.
So we paid off the mob and they gave us in return to banditos too young mobsters
who would go everywhere with us.
They lived in our hotel,
they stayed with us.
They went on tours with us.
They weren't,
they were did everything with us.
Their names are eager and Sasha and when we got our teaser was like,
listen,
this is Igor and Sasha.
They will be ghosting us with my teacher who was there with me.
It was like during the fucking mob,
Igor inside go inside.
They were guy named Bruce and they were like,
and they were,
oh,
it gets worse.
So,
so they like,
listen,
whatever you do to our class,
do not talk to them.
Do not interact with them.
Do not engage them.
They're only here to shadow it.
So in my head I'm like fucking get to know these guys,
right?
Like get a bottle of vodka,
a six pack of Baltic,
go knock on their door.
Now mind you,
I speak no Russian at the time,
no rushing because I'd never studied in any of the classes.
So first night there a knock on Igor in Sasha's room and they're having a party
in there and like fucking all their friends are in their room.
They lived right next to me and Kendra,
my teacher lived across the hall from Igor.
So knock on their door,
Igor opens the door and he looks like a fucking thug.
He's got,
he's got like a wife beater on a cigarette of beer and he just looks at me in
Russia and he just goes sto.
And now the second he says that I start panicking.
All the phrases I had in my head that I was trying to say all disappear.
And all I say to Igor in Russian is I am the machine.
And so,
but I just said,
y'all machine though.
And he went stole.
And now I don't know what I said.
I'm like,
did it,
what did I just say?
I'll fuck you up.
Like,
and I go,
I go,
I am the machine.
And he goes,
say it again.
I said,
I have let me scene.
And then he starts laughing and he brings me into the room and he's like,
hold on,
say it again.
And so I say it to the room,
I don't know what the fuck I'm saying.
I'm like,
I'm the machine.
And they're like,
you're the machine and the machine.
I said that all fucking night with these guys.
That's the communication we had.
As I said on the machine and Igor and Sasha and I became best friends,
right?
We did everything together.
If we went on a field trip,
they would tell me,
machine,
you don't need to go on the field trips,
come drink with us.
So now,
uh,
cut to one day we have to take a train to Moscow.
No different mob.
Ran The train to Moscow and a driftwood,
Tra tra Marbury and Moscow and Igor,
Sasha,
we're not allowed to cross boundaries and it's all me.
They said,
listen,
we're not going to go with you,
but we've taken care of you.
We've talked to the mobsters on the train and in Moscow because we had to pay
them too.
They,
they weren't allowed to come with you.
There weren't allowed to come with us.
And we're paying a different mob now to protect us on the train,
making a different mob to protect us in Moscow.
Holy Shit.
So they said,
we've taken care of it.
Don't worry about it.
So they take me to the train and uh,
they introduced me to our tune.
Who?
Gangsters?
Igor.
Where do you three words that afford dude's Igor.
And there's not a lot of names in Russia.
It's Alex.
Igor or Sascha.
What about fuel?
So,
so Igor,
Igor,
he,
my ego says,
so these are yours.
This is the machine.
If you give them alcohol,
you'll have a great time.
So even when you like through the roof,
they were like,
awesome.
Don't worry,
we've taken care of you.
We were sitting in first class.
You're not sitting with your class.
You're sitting in first class to Moscow.
And I'm like,
Holy Shit,
this is what I'm talking about.
And I bring another guy,
John Bolshoi,
big John.
I bring him with me to go sit in first class.
And sure enough,
man,
we were fucking FirstClass just meet these two.
Igor is John the conductor?
I shit you not the conductor before the train takes off,
comes into the room.
I swear to you,
rips off the band on this thing.
Says this is the president for the machine.
It would be an honor to do a shot with you.
And I'm like,
Whoa,
this is fucking right.
So I do a shot with its conductor and we pound this vodka within like fucking
30,
45 minutes.
We're done all the vodka in the room.
Whoa.
We're drinking hard.
And my classes all in coach and I'm sitting in first class and eat more Negro.
Like let's go get more Ivanka.
And I'm like,
done it.
These guys run the fucking train.
So we get up,
we walk into the bar cart and a biggie or says machine,
grab a Apollo,
uh,
grab,
grab some bread club.
And I'm like,
that's bread.
I'm understanding Russia.
He's like,
grab some Sia,
this cheese.
I'm like,
I'm learning Russian.
I'm looking at,
John is standing behind me.
It's like,
eh.
He's like,
Grandpa,
can I go?
I know that one.
And he's like,
grab all the money,
grab all the rubels.
And I go,
what?
I look around and were robbing the bar cart.
What?
The bartender standing like this.
Everyone's standing against the wall and I'm sitting behind the bar with a
handful of rubles,
a bottle of vodka and a thing of bread going,
holy fuck.
John looks at me.
And he's like,
just take it.
Let's go take all the fucking cash out of the bar.
Cart,
bartender doings,
not making eye contact every and their pat.
Everyone just lets it happen.
It's the mob.
They ran everything in Russia.
Everything.
Wow.
And so we get done and we go back to our room and it's a totally different
energy,
like very like very sketchy,
you know?
And,
and he freaked out.
Now I'm free talks.
I'm like,
fuck,
I just robbed the car like no one else saw anyone rubbed.
The bark are except for me and my teacher,
Val,
who's at the time was our chaperone,
didn't speak any Russian.
She comes to our first class cart,
opens the door and says,
I need to talk to you right now.
And I was like,
listen,
and she goes,
I told you that you're in big trouble.
You I my classmate,
your classmates that told me what happened big where it takes a sip of vodka,
spits in her eyes and goes,
no one talks to the machine like that.
I'm like,
whoa.
He spit vodka in her eyes,
fucking it is and the,
and then shuts the door and then it looks at me and he says,
don't worry,
I got you.
When it gets dark,
we're going to have a lot of fun and he pulls out a thing,
a keys.
He's got keys to the whole fucking train.
He's like,
we're going to rob everyone when the,
when it gets dark now I'm like,
fuck,
why did I get myself into like,
this is bad news,
bad fucking news.
So we get stark and sure enough,
then we start robbing the train.
Go through my class first.
We'd fucking open the door.
Literally Norma crawl in,
pull the bags out.
John and I would go through them and try not to steal like anything important
and Biggie or would stand guard.
And if anyone woke up,
he'd take us civil vodka and spit in their face.
And it was,
I mean,
it's sketchy now.
It's sketchy.
It's not even fun.
These guys aren't fucking,
no,
no.
They're loaded though.
They're hammered.
Piss drunk.
We rubbed my whole class and then,
uh,
and then we end up,
they end up taking off and going into the car and me and John are sitting in,
in the first class car just thinking,
we're fucked,
man.
We're fucked.
We robbed the train.
We prompt the bar cart and they come back and they're just fucking angry,
drunk,
like piss angry drunk.
We pull in Moscow and my teacher,
Val,
uh,
comes to the door,
opens it and said,
I'm just letting you know,
we've called the police.
So it was like,
fuck.
So Igor,
Igor,
Igor like,
fuck it.
Don't worry.
Fuck the police.
This is Russia.
Who the fuck she thinks she is?
This isn't America.
This is Russia.
We run everything.
I'm like,
Ugh,
I'm going to fucking go to the gulag.
Sure enough.
Sure enough,
man,
the cops are sitting on the,
on the middle,
like the middle.
You know where people get off the train,
that little receiving area.
My class is sitting there,
my whole class or in the pajamas,
they're crying.
Their bags had been gone through their fucking giving statements to the cops and
the cops are writing them down and I'm sitting with Igor and Igor and John in
the fucking car and they're just still drinking and smoking and they're like,
fuck this.
Fuck this.
We'll take care of this right now.
They walk outside out to the cops and start yelling at the cops and I'm like,
mother Fucker,
this is not how I would have taken care of this.
Just,
I don't know.
I don't even know what they're saying,
but they're just shouting in.
The cops are shouting back and then finally biggie or just starts pointing at me
and I'm like,
oh,
he's been in this whole fucking thing on me.
Like I'm going down for the whole thing.
And then the cop starts pointing at me and telling me exists as it did.
It's by the owner or whatever he's saying,
come here right now.
So I fucking walk out.
And it's that moment where you find the hash on your body.
You know they find it and you're going to jail forever.
Is that that moment that walk where your asshole gets cold and you're like,
this is it that express fucking,
that's the moment.
And I'll walk all the way across the soul fucking trailer to get to him.
I get right up to the cop and the cop looks at me and he goes,
I understand you're the machine.
And I was like,
yeah.
And he goes,
tonight,
you party with us.
What?
Right.
So then we went out and partied with these cops.
So the cops did nothing,
fucking nothing.
They were so excited to meet the machine.
What's it really like?
This fucking,
it was the,
it was,
it has,
it was a nickname there no one funny in Russia.
Is that what it is?
No,
there was no,
there was no humor.
There was no with you.
Is that what it is?
Is,
is no one funny.
And then you come along and you're hilarious.
So they were like,
we're partying with you.
Yeah.
And I was,
and I was just loud.
Like there's not a lot of Lao people like you.
Would you be willing to move to Russia to be their bitch and to like,
Nah Dude,
those guys scared me one night.
The guy did you party with these guys?
Oh,
I party with Igor.
And you were on the train only.
And then I partied with the cops in Moscow with John and then for one night and
then we hid from them cause they want it.
They like the cops wanted,
uh,
the cops were ski were scary.
More scary than the gangsters because they,
you,
they could not get in trouble.
Like they either were like,
drive my cop car and you're like,
what the fuck drive my cop cost.
Fucking do they drive on the left side of the same side as us?
Uh,
I don't remember.
I was there for three months.
You'd think I'd know.
I have no idea.
I was drawing on the same side as us,
but they,
I mean like the whole experience in Russia was just amuse.
Just,
I remember one time we,
Igor and you're going to,
Sasha had said they were going to get a boat for us for Russian may day or Labor
Day.
And they're like,
yeah,
we got to,
um,
they're going to have a big boat for our whole class.
We're all going out in the boat.
So I get up early for the day,
we're going out on the boat and I go over to his room and Igor is eating dried
fish,
drinking beers.
And I was like,
what's better?
And he's like,
I'm fucked.
I go,
what?
And he goes,
we got no boat.
Like,
what do you mean?
He goes,
I've,
I've tried everything to try to get a boat.
I can't get a fucking boat.
And we've promised the class of boat for the tour is supposed to have a boat.
And so we're like,
oh fuck.
And he goes,
and then all the sudden the phone rings and he goes,
we got a boat.
I go,
we do.
And he goes,
yeah.
So we start walking to the dock,
we're carrying a fucking big case of beer,
my whole class cameras and fucking to their little passports around their neck.
And one of his buddies just walks up and he's like,
hey.
And he's like,
And then we just get to the dock and there's a boat there and we get on it and
take off.
And halfway through we realize like,
I just stole the fucking boat.
He just stole the boat.
And he was like rushing must be just fucking crazy.
Insane.
We went to,
went to a big mob boss party one night and he was like,
tells them my boss.
He goes,
this is the machine,
this is the guy who does this all happen.
It just was loud.
And then,
and then I was partying with Eagle and Sasha so much that like that.
And they just tell their friends or you gotta meet this guy,
you gotta meet this guy.
He's so funny.
We're going to have to drink with you and then we're going to do shots with
Brooke crusher.
You gotta be careful,
man.
You were selling yourself as this incredible fun party guy and everyone's going
to want to do shots with you.
Oh,
I don't,
I'm,
I'm fucking,
are you friends with Igor on Facebook now?
Have you?
I tried to find him a lot.
I follow you on Twitter.
It's really fascinating.
And,
and like their stories.
I had to put in the book,
I had to put the machine in.
I can't not write that in there.
And there's a lot of,
there's like the Will Smith Story.
I had to put it in,
but then I wanted to do the cerebral palsy one.
I wanted to do one where I met Ralph Sampson and when I was a kid I was,
I got off Thompson.
Um,
he was a basketball player and I was,
I went to school at,
I went to,
I was like in eighth grade I decided I really want to be a basketball player and
so I went to Villanova basketball camp and Ralph Sampson came to speak and like
the first night I got a concussion and the two best basketball players got
pulled out for drinking.
So the next day I had to sit out with two that's basketball players and everyone
thought we drank together.
So now all of a sudden I'm 15,
14 and everyone thinks I'm cool because I'm partying with the 18 year olds.
So Ralph Sampson comes,
I thought this defined me.
Ralph Sampson comes up to give a speech.
He's like,
I'm here to talk to you about two things.
There's 5,000 kids on the gym floor.
He said,
we were talking about basketball and we're talking about discipline first let's
talk about discipline.
Who in here?
Parties.
And I was under the impression we were all going to put our hands up,
but I was the only fucking person.
I just went trunk and he was like,
oh,
one person,
5,000 kids.
No one raised her fucking hand.
He's like,
how do you party?
I was fucking 13 I know how to,
I didn't,
I never partied in my life.
So all I said was hardy and he fucking lost it.
And 5,000 kids are slapping the gym floor.
Like,
Oh shit,
we're going to make an example out of you.
Party animal.
He's lost the room.
So he brings me up front to the in front of all the kids and he makes me stand
up and he puts a basketball behind my legs like this.
And then one on my arms like this.
And he's like,
we party hardy.
What?
We're going to party hardy today.
So I'm standing like this for his whole fucking hour speech with basketball here
and there.
And he's like,
and he keeps coming back to me.
And by the way,
I'm so in my head that I have social anxiety disorder,
but I'm in front of everyone and I'm like being made fun.
I'm being mocked that I wasn't listening to his question.
Somebody was like,
you think you'll ever party again?
I just said,
yeah,
and the fucking place went bananas.
They're like,
oh.
And he's like,
how do you party hardy?
I was like,
and I didn't know the answer.
I just was like,
with two hands,
fucking people are losing.
You think you do marijuana and now I'm killing it.
I'm like,
I'll get to in college and these kids,
I left that gym and everyone wanted to talk to me.
Everyone's like party animal.
What are you doing and that you're still holding the basketball between your
legs the whole fucking time.
You're cracking jokes while I'm cracking jokes.
And how long did you hold the basketball?
An hour.
That's a long time by my cousin Abe almost brought him here today.
I should have,
I didn't even think about it.
My cousin aid was there at the camp even cause he's from Philly.
I didn't know anyone.
My cousin,
he was like,
I didn't,
I didn't know you partied.
I go,
I don't,
I don't.
I just thought we'd all put our fucking hands up.
He's like,
no.
Why would you put your hands up if you don't party?
I was like,
I want it to be cool.
So yeah,
so like so now and then everyone would come up and they'd be like,
party animal,
you partying harder.
I'd be like,
yeah.
But then I became cool at that camp and then I have friends and so I wrote that
story is a little longer and I gave it to them.
I go,
this is the best story.
This defines me.
And they're like,
oh I'm not really.
That's hilarious.
So it's all partying stories,
but it's like that's a hilarious story.
Oh thanks.
Oh nutty.
That this could have possibly sent you on a path when you were that young.
Yeah.
Know 13 years old.
I just,
I,
and it's all just wanting to be accepted.
I remember.
Did you ever have one of those moments where you'd go somewhere and you didn't
know anybody?
Sure.
But you felt like everyone fucking grew up together.
Yeah.
That's a weird feeling.
I felt like that a lot as a kid.
Yeah.
But I thought that that define me.
Cause then I became the Po.
I became the party animal that kind of lived up to whatever I,
by the way,
I went to high school the very next year.
It didn't know anyone,
so I'm sure that kind of,
I was like,
well,
it worked in Villanova,
so
[inaudible]
okay.